We've been talking about the type one
a supernova and the data that they
provide,
uh,
about the expansion and as it turns out,
acceleration of the universe.
And so one way to,
to summarize all that information
is that what we have found out.
We now know that,
uh,
the universe is accelerating,
not just expanding,
but accelerating.
And that acceleration comes about because
of some kind of dark energy or to turn
it around the label we give to whatever
is calling that is dark energy.
And,
uh,
this sometimes gets
summarized by this quantity,
uh,
which is the energy
density of the dark energy,
uh,
relative to the critical
density of the universe.
And the fact that it's accelerating
means that this quantity must be greater
than this other quantity,
the density of matter,
cause the matter tends
to pull things together.
And so,
uh,
we know not only that it's accelerating,
we know something about how much it is
accelerating and that tells us how much
bigger this,
uh,
the dark energy density is
than the matter density.
Uh,
and we kind of know by how much and
we kind of know how much bigger.
Uh,
yes,
he is the head,
uh,
the dark energy,
the dark matter density.
Um,
but somebody point,
somebody actually asked the question,
uh,
that,
you know,
I keep saying,
well,
uh,
this is like,
this is like three quarters
and this is like one quarter.
Uh,
if you add a bunch of manor,
couldn't you just add
a bunch of dark energy?
Also had an top,
uh,
with the same amount of acceleration.
So a comparable universe
and the answer's yes.
You could.
Uh,
there's nothing in the supernova data
that prohibits this from being 0.5 and
this from being one,
uh,
as long as this is sufficiently greater
than that by the amount necessary to
give rise to the observed acceleration.
And so if you plot these two
quantities against each other,
so here's a kind of zero,
zero.
Actually this can be negative,
but let's not,
let's not go there.
Uh,
one,
uh,
what you find out is that,
there's a kind of a loud region
that's sort of looks like this.
Okay.
Allowed by the Supernova data.
Notice.
This is a,
I'm assuming throughout that the,
that the dark energy really
is the cosmological constant.
I'm not thinking about the big rip
scenarios at the moment because that would
add a third dimension,
this plot.
And I don't want to do that just yet.
Um,
so assume this is all assuming the dark
energy is the cosmological constant,
but that's certainly a place to start.
There's no reason not to do that.
And so,
uh,
I've been kind of consistently claiming a,
as we've been talking about the course
that the real answer is somewhere like
here,
yeah.
That it's about 0.3 on the matter side,
0.25 and about three quarters,
two thirds,
three quarters on the dark energy side.
Uh,
but in fact,
you could go,
uh,
as far as the Supernova care,
you could have no matter at all and just
a little dark energy or you could have
a lot of matter and a huge amount of
dark energy and you'd get the same amount
of acceleration and therefore satisfy
the observational constraints.
But in fact,
it turns out we know more than this.
And,
uh,
because there are other constraints
on cosmology besides the supernovae.
And I have to tell you at this point that,
uh,
this course,
the way I've presented it is a little
bit lopsided because the other ways of
constraining,
uh,
these two quantities are just
as important as the supernovae.
And I'm going to do
them all in one lecture.
Uh,
and this is kind of in the spirit of the
philosophy of this course where we try
and understand a few things in
depth rather than many things,
uh,
in breadth.
But,
uh,
I'm going to talk about to,
to other,
uh,
kinds of constraints on cosmology today,
which are in fact justice important to
modern cosmology is the supernovae are,
I liked the supernovae first of all,
because they were the first
evidence of dark energy.
I still think they're the best
enter evidence of dark energy,
but it's also true that I think they're
in some ways the easiest to understand
that's not quite right.
What it,
what I mean is that you don't need a whole
bunch of physics to understand what's
going on.
Cause it's just,
it's just expansion.
The expansion of the,
of the universe,
whereas some of these other things,
uh,
as you will see,
there's a moment where
I'm going to have to say,
and then there's a whole bunch of
complicated physics and then you get the
result.
And so it's less satisfying to,
to teach and perhaps
to learn and of course,
like,
yes,
but,
but equally important
for modern cosmology.
And what that,
uh,
what these other things do is they
pick out where in the allowed region,
regional,
loud from the supernovae,
uh,
the real universe actually.
Yes.
Okay.
So,
uh,
with the understanding that either of
the two things I'm about to talk about,
could have been five weeks of this course.
Let's move in and I'll try and explain
in brief what these things tell us about
the universe.
The first is the cosmic
microwave background.
This we've encountered before,
uh,
this was one of the proofs that
the big bang really is the really,
as opposed to the steady state.
And,
uh,
I don't know if you remember
what we said about that.
So let me remind you,
uh,
recall what was going on.
You're looking back in
time as you look far away.
So as you look back,
things are denser and hotter,
and if you look back far enough,
they get really hot.
Uh,
so let us imagine we're
looking at a red shift,
not have one or 0.8 or
something like that,
but at a red shift of 3000,
uh,
so this is when the
universe was three 10,000.
The scale factor of the university
3000 times smaller than it is today.
At that time,
uh,
the temperature,
the average temperature of the universe
about 10,000 degrees turns out that's an
interesting number because 10,000 degrees
is how hot it has to be for hydrogen
to ionize.
Ionization,
you'll remember is when the electrons
disassociate with the protons and then you
just have a whole bunch of
charged particles moving around.
Uh,
and it turns out I,
so before that,
when the temperature's higher than this,
you imagined that the entire universe
is basically filled with all this ionize
hydrogen.
Uh,
one of the features of ionized hydrogen
or deed charged particles generally is
that they tend to be opaque.
Photons don't propagate
well through these things.
And photons propagate well
through neutral materials,
but not well through charge materials.
So,
uh,
before that,
the universe was opaque.
It's like looking at
the surface of a star.
Big Wall of opaque gas.
You can't see any further.
So I can't look back
any further than that.
Uh,
but if you look in any direction
and you're looking far enough away,
you want to see a big wall
of 10,000 degree hydrogen.
Uh,
and in fact,
we know what a wall of 10,000 degree
hydrogen looks like because there are,
there are stars who
surfaces are 10,000 degrees.
Uh,
and the sun's a little a
little cooler than that,
but there are many stars
that are 10,000 trees.
So this should look like,
so in any direction you look,
you should see
something that looks
like the surface of the,
of a star,
uh,
a hot I and ISED hydrogen,
and this looks like the surface of a star
and we know that that's wrong,
right?
Uh,
you left to go outside,
look up in some direction.
Uh,
if this were really true,
right,
then anywhere you look,
you would see the surface of this,
of,
of a star that's hotter and
brighter than the sun and salt.
The whole of the sky would look
like the surface of the sun,
only hotter.
Uh,
and obviously that isn't the case.
and the reason that that's not the case
is you have to remember how red shifted
this is,
it's red shifted by a factor of 3000.
So the light is three has wavelengths
that's 3000 times longer than the like we
see from stars.
So let's work that out.
Uh,
you'll recall a lambda that
you observe is equal to lamp,
admitted plus Delta Lambda,
uh,
or is equal to lambda,
emitted a one plus xe because xe
is Delta Lambda overlapped it.
He made it.
Uh,
and so this is equal to the
wave length emitted times 3001.
Right?
Here's the one.
Here's the 3000.
We'll call that three
times 10 to the three.
And if the wavelength,
15 minute is a nice optical wavelength,
like five times 10 to
the minus seven meters,
uh,
that looks green or yellow,
times 3000,
that's a 15 times 10 to the minus four.
That's around one millimeter
wavelengths of a millimeter.
Now,
wavelengths of the millimeter
you don't see with your eye.
These are more or less
what we call micro waves.
So the prediction really is
that in any direction you look,
you see,
uh,
a whole,
but you see what would have been
something that looks like the surface of a
star,
except it's red shifted so far that all
you can see is microwaves instead of
ordinary optical light.
This is true.
This has been verified,
a verified observationally
at first in the 1960s.
Uh,
and this is true,
uh,
there is a cosmic microwave background,
in any direction.
Take a microwave detector,
radio,
telescope and pointed in any direction.
You see this stuff
coming from the universe.
And this was taken when
it was first discovered,
uh,
as,
evidence for the Big Bang
and against the steady state
because,
uh,
it was predicted by the big bank because
you assume that the universe was much,
much hotter and much,
much denser in the past,
which is what you need in order to create
this stuff and that buy enough time.
You're seeing it now,
it's all red shifted.
Okay.
So that's fine.
As far as it goes,
one of the features of the
cosmic microwave background
turns out to be that it's
very smooth.
Uh,
and you expect that to be true.
Yeah.
Uh,
because you expect to see the
exact same thing in any direction.
It doesn't matter if you go back in
time looking that way or back in time
looking that way.
You expect the universe to be denser
and hotter in the past in about the same
way.
And so,
sure enough,
uh,
the cosmic microwave background,
it's pretty much the same everywhere.
You look the same everywhere.
Uh,
and as further experiments were done,
it really is very smooth.
And it,
you came,
uh,
started to,
to the,
the smoothness of this started to become
a little embarrassing because it can't
be you.
You don't want it to be perfectly smooth,
absolutely,
totally identical in all directions
because the universe at the moment is not
perfectly smooth.
We've got planets,
we got people,
we got galaxies,
then we got big spaces
where there's nothing.
And so if the universe at the time of
the cosmic microwave background is going
to evolve into our own universe,
now there must be some little
perturbations that are gonna grow up to be
galaxies later on.
Uh,
if it were perfectly smooth,
then,
uh,
it would have to be perfectly smooth now,
and that's manifestly not the case.
So,
uh,
but you still,
you suspect that there must
be some irregularities,
uh,
because the universe now
is clearly a irregular,
yeah,
yeah.
In the sense that there are,
it contains objects of various kinds.
And so in the 1990s,
it turns out you can see
microwaves from the ground,
but it's better to do it from space.
Uh,
and saw in the 1990s,
they launched a satellite called Colby.
This is the cosmic background.
Explorer
is this a satellite,
uh,
launched in the early 1990s and Kolby
finally found the variations in the cosmic
microwave background
and they were very small,
uh,
ten one part in 100,000,
so 10 to the minus five to one.
Now that contrast with the variations
we see in the current universe and the
current universe,
uh,
the variations in density can be,
30 orders of magnitude 10 to the 30.
Remember,
the average density of the universe
is something like 10 to the minus 27,
uh,
kilograms per cubic meter.
In here we've got 10 to
the three cubic kill,
uh,
kilograms per cubic meter.
That's the density of water,
for example.
And so the density of the universe
now varies by 10 to the 30.
Uh,
but then it only measures
varied by 10 to the minus five.
So,
uh,
the sixth decimal place in the,
in the density was found to be variable
on the first five were always the same.
Now 10 to the 30.
Uh,
and so that seems like this university
is quite different from this universe,
but there are ways that structure grows.
And that's that I'll
come back to in a minute.
That's the second thing I want to
talk about is the growth of structure.
Uh,
but at least there was some variation.
People were very excited
about this because this again,
is a situation where something was
predicted and then you build a complicated
piece of apparatus and
you see what you predict,
and that's always a good thing to have
happen that gives you confidence that you
know what you're talking about.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in their excitement,
a number of scientists
became sort of overexcited.
There's a famous quote from
Stephen Hawking at the time,
he said,
uh,
about the Colby results.
He said,
it's like seeing the face of God.
This is a very dangerous
thing to say because,
you know,
most people in the world don't
understand how similes work.
Uh,
so he said,
it's like seeing the,
the,
the face of God.
And this was reported.
Scientists sees God.
Uh,
so you have to watch what you say
and,
uh,
and you know,
the weekly world news got a hold
of this and then it was trouble.
Um,
all right.
So they saw god by seeing the variations
in the cosmic microwave background,
who knew?
Um,
all right now then,
uh,
so that was nice.
Uh,
but Colby was just the first crack at
this and while they saw variations,
uh,
they didn't see it very precisely.
It was a pretty blurry imaging image.
So,
uh,
then there was another satellite,
still operating,
actually called w map.
AW map is the,
uh,
Wilkinson micro wave,
anisotropy
probe.
So anti sought,
drippy,
it means irregularity a Wilkinson.
Dave Wilkinson was,
uh,
one of the pioneers of this
kind of radio astronomy,
uh,
and he was the leader of this project
until he died shortly before launch.
And so then they named it after him.
Uh,
and uh,
then in 2003,
a w map,
uh,
announced its result and they got a
much more precise map of the cosmic
microwave background,
uh,
so precise that they could measure
the size of these irregularities.
Yes.
Not just how irregular they weren't,
but how big they were.
Okay.
And that it turns out,
gives you cosmological information.
And I'll come back to that in a second,
but I want to start by showing
you some pictures here.
Um,
let's see.
Right,
this is the Colby results.
So let me explain what you're looking at.
What you're looking at is
a map of the entire sky.
They've projected it on to,
uh,
the sky in the way it works is,
this down the middle here.
That's the,
uh,
that's the plain of the galaxy.
That's where the Milky Way is going to be.
And then any position on
the sky maps onto this oval.
And so this is a common way
of expressing the whole Scott.
Now this,
uh,
this is actually kind of
the raw data where red,
I can't remember which way it goes.
I think red is slightly denser
or actually slightly hotter.
There's the way they measure it,
uh,
and blue is slightly cooler.
So there's this kind of Yin Yang,
a pattern here.
And that's because we're moving in
some direction through the universe.
And so,
uh,
if you look at the micro of background
in the direction we're moving,
uh,
then it,
then it's a little bit blue shifted,
which makes it look a little bit hotter.
Whereas where if you look back
where we're coming from a,
that's a little bit a red shifted,
so it looks a little cooler.
And so we're moving in this
direction away from here.
And,
uh,
that effect,
this very small effect of our
own motion through the universe,
uh,
turns out to dominate,
the,
uh,
irregularities and the
cosmic microwave background.
But of course,
that's not what we care about.
Uh,
we want to see what the
background itself is doing.
It's also true that that's
quite easy to remove,
uh,
because,
we know,
uh,
how fast we're moving.
Uh,
you can tell from this what
direction we're moving in.
I had to also how fast,
and you can just take
that out of the whole map,
uh,
and,
and adjust the map to be how we would
see it if we weren't moving anywhere that
looks like this.
And now there's a clear signal.
This is the,
this is the Milky Way here.
There are sources of microwaves that
aren't the cosmic microwave background.
There a objects in our own galaxy,
uh,
that,
he met lot of microwaves.
But the thing is that the spectrum of
the microwaves de mint is very different
from the spectrum of the
cosmic microwave background.
And so if you take not
just an image of this,
but you take a,
an actual spectrum,
which they did a,
you can tell the difference
between things coming,
uh,
emission coming from the background and
emission coming from actual objects in
our own galaxy.
Uh,
and so you can take out the ones,
you can artificially digitally remove
the objects that have the spectrum
associated with a galactic objects.
And so you can do that.
You can take this out and
that's what you end up.
I should say that the scale
between red and blue changes,
uh,
by about a factor of 10 between
each one of these plots.
Uh,
and so the difference between
red and blue here is much,
much smaller than the difference
between red and blue up here.
Anyway,
this was the face of God
according to Hawking,
uh,
because it wasn't smooth.
And because you could,
after some exhaustive error analysis,
convince yourself that you really
believe that these pieces of the cosmic
microwave background
are actually hotter and,
uh,
therefore dancer,
then these pieces of the
cosmic microwave background.
So that was a big triumph.
And these irregularities
then grow up to be galaxies,
uh,
or groups of galaxies or
groups of groups of galaxies.
Cause you know,
they're pretty big.
They extend,
you know,
some significant fraction
across the whole universe.
Uh,
this is,
you know,
a map of the whole universe cause
it's mapping the entire sky.
Uh,
so they're not going to grow
up to be individual galaxies,
but they are,
uh,
going to grow up to be
irregularities in the universe.
Okay.
So now this is coping in the 1990s to
compare that to the WWE map result here
is,
uh,
on a different,
visualization color scheme.
A Cove beach,
uh,
w map changed colors on us so that you
wouldn't get confused between their
results in the Coby results.
So this is the Cobi map again,
uh,
in the,
and this is what w map saw and you can
see that it's seeing the same things,
uh,
this over density here.
That's this stuff here,
this over here.
That's these,
uh,
only it's seeing it much,
much,
much more precisely.
Uh,
and you know,
it's kind of the difference between a
Hubble space telescope image in a ground
based image.
It seeing the same thing,
but the resolution here is much,
much higher.
And you can see that you might have a
chance of measuring the size of some of
these clumps in this image in a way
that you wouldn't be able to do in this
image here.
And so that was what w map was all about,
was actually measuring the sizes of these
little bumps in the cosmic microwave
background.
So why is that a good thing to do?
And here is where,
uh,
if I had five weeks,
I'd explain that to you,
but I don't,
so I won't.
So let me just say that from the sizes
you can get cosmological information.
I'm not going to tell you how that works.
Basically it comes about because,
uh,
if you,
you can feel what you find out from
this is that there are certain sizes,
the clumps like to be certain sizes and
there very few clumps that are other
sizes.
So they're particularly favored
sizes and the favored sizes,
a turnout to relate to how old is at that
moment and what has been contained in
the universe up til then.
Uh,
but I won't go into that in any
more detail except to say that the,
uh,
the outcome of this is
that what you constrain,
what you find out from this is
what they refer to as Omega total,
which is the sum of Omega
Lambda and Omega matter.
And this turns out to be equal to one,
to as close as they've
been able to measure it.
It's about 10% by now one,
uh,
probably plus or minus,
I don't know.
Oh 0.1.
It's maybe a little
better than that by now.
Few percent.
But now that's a very good thing to know
because remember what this looked like
from the supernovae alone,
the allowed region of the supercell.
Here's one and one.
And they are loud region of the
supernovae looks something like this.
The cosmic microwave background
has these two things equally one.
And so you force yourself to be on a
straight line that looks like that.
And so the two of these
experiments put together,
gives you a much better constraint,
um,
what's going on.
So this is from the microwave background
and now,
uh,
it's actually some kind of
region that looks like this.
And so now you've got an allowed region
that's much smaller than either of these
two experiments,
uh,
put together a individually.
Okay.
As I said,
there's a third constraint and this
comes about by the growth of structure
you have to get from these
tiny perturbations that
after great effort have been
seen in the cosmic microwave background,
those head better grow
up to be galaxies or,
uh,
groups of galaxies or something.
So at,
uh,
at z equals 3000,
you have 10 to the minus
five perturbations,
uh,
at z equals zero.
You have 10 to the 30,
uh,
plus even greater than that,
you know,
that basically a black
hole is infinitely dance.
So,
uh,
I guess you could have
infinite perturbations if
you think about it from that
point of view and you've got
to get from one to the other.
So how does this work?
Supposing you have a slight over density,
well what happens?
The region that is over dance a little
dancer than the stuff around it has more
gravity
than the surrounding regions.
And so it then pulls in material from
the neighboring areas because uh,
the gravitational force on
any particular piece of mass,
we'll pull it toward the place where
the matter is densest cause that's where
the gravity is coming from,
polls in nearby material.
But of course that action makes it denser
cause it's just pulled in more stuff
from the nearby region is it
makes the other parts less dense.
Uh,
and so this is a runaway process.
Then the dancer regions are dancers still,
they have yet more gravity.
They pull stuff in even faster.
And so you could start
with tiny perturbations and
they grow and grow and grow
and grow until it becomes the difference
between a galaxy and not a galaxy or a
of galaxies.
Turns out that the con,
even on the,
uh,
w map plot,
the kinds of perturbations we're
looking at are what's called large.
This leads to the large scale structure.
Yeah.
Which is,
uh,
distributions of galaxies of
galaxies and galaxy clusters.
So there's individual galaxies,
galaxies like to live in clusters.
Turns out the clusters
are grouped together.
That's the large scale structure.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you can pluck this by using,
by doing galaxy surveys.
A problem with the galaxy survey is how
do you know where it is in the third
dimension?
How do you know how far,
how far away it is?
A,
so you have position in the sky that
tells you to have the coordinates of the
galaxy,
and then you measure its red shift
and you use the red shift,
uh,
in order to make a guess at how far away
it is just from using the Hubble loss.
So instead of trying to determine the
distance in order to measure the value of
the Hubble constant,
you assume a value of the Hubble constant.
Did you take from somewhere?
Uh,
and then if you measure,
uh,
then you can,
and once you've assumed the
value of the Hubble constant,
you can use redshift to tell you
what the distance is supposed to be.
And so then you get a
three d map of the sky,
uh,
and uh,
and that tells us what the structure is.
Now
you can then compare that to,
uh,
you can then simulate the growth
of,
uh,
growth of structure
by,
uh,
by computer.
You start with the cosmic microwave
background with what you know about the
cosmic microwave background.
Uh,
you apply the laws of gravity
ad.
You can also put in a little
dark energy if you feel like it,
to,
uh,
change how the group,
and that actually does change how the
growth works as you might imagine.
But you can stick in any
cosmological parameters you want,
uh,
and just apply them for the,
for,
uh,
as the universe grows from
a red shift of 3002 to now.
Uh,
and then you determine
what,
uh,
the simulation looks like now,
where now is defined to be,
you know,
13.7 billion years after you start,
uh,
and you ask,
does it look alike?
Look
the same as the observations.
Uh,
uh,
now
along the way,
when you're applying
gravity and all this stuff,
you have to assume,
uh,
cosmological parameters,
how much dark energy there is,
but especially how much,
uh,
dark matter there is because
it's the matter that's pulling,
uh,
that's pulling these density
perturbations together,
how much dark matter and,
and some of its properties.
And so then what you do is you just run
your computer program a whole bunch of
times over and over again with
different amounts of dark energy,
dark matter and stuff like that.
And you see which one of them of these
simulations produces a universe that
actually looks like the one we see.
So,
which,
uh,
input parameters,
ew,
ew.
The observations.
So this is in general how
computational science works.
This is how,
you know,
the big global warming models,
all these kinds of things work this way.
Uh,
you take a,
you put in as much physics,
as much chemistry,
whatever.
As you can understand,
you make a big computer simulation,
you pick a stet set of
starting conditions.
Uh,
in this case,
that's easy because you observe
the cosmic microwave background,
you run the thing for a while and
you ask does it look like real life?
And to the extent that
it looks like real life,
you believe that you've put in all the
important physics and all the important
science into your simulation.
Then you ask,
all right,
uh,
given the results of this simulation,
the,
that seems to represent real life,
what does it predict?
Uh,
you.
So you can do things,
for example,
in the global warming Matsu add a whole
bunch of carbon to the atmosphere.
And then you ask,
well,
now what's going to happen?
Uh,
and uh,
with,
with various results.
Uh,
and so this is a kind of example of,
of a general kind of science that is
now more and more frequently being done,
uh,
this kind of computational
simulation of reality,
which you then check in
some way against reality.
And then to the extent that it works,
you use it to predict reality
in other sets of circumstances.
Uh,
so let me show you some of that.
All right.
Here's a map of the universe.
This is,
these are observations.
This is a famous,
uh,
redshift survey.
So what you've got is red
shift going up this way,
or actually they plotted in velocity and
position on the sky in this direction.
This is kind of a slice of the universe,
so it's got no third dimension coming out
of the blackboard cause they just have
music.
And you can see each.is a galaxy.
They are not distributed
randomly in this plot.
Uh,
this,
uh,
little guy here,
is,
uh,
obviously hugely over dance.
There are also places they think
they're complete out to the edge here.
There are also places where
there are almost no galaxies.
These are called void.
There are walls and void.
Uh,
and then as they took more and more
slices to build up the third dimension,
uh,
they ended up having things
that look like death.
Uh,
and there are clear over densities at sir.
This was named the Great Wall.
Uh,
there are clear over densities in some
places and clear under densities in
others.
And it turns out that the large scale
structure of the universe is sort of,
uh,
like a bubble.
Uh,
some soap bubbles.
and so they've got walls.
And then there are voids in the middle
of the walls and where those walls
connect,
or particularly dense clumps.
Uh,
now that way you can think about it is
that they're kind of these filaments
things that,
uh,
go through space where they're
unusually large numbers of galaxies.
So the most recent,
uh,
redshift survey,
which goes out much,
much further than the
one I just showed you,
that was the first that
one of goes out to here.
But now they've,
uh,
the,
to DF two degree field.
This is a,
uh,
a telescope that can look at,
measure the redshifts of galaxies within
two degrees of each other all at the
same time.
So you get many,
many retrofits.
I think they have close to maybe
a hundred thousand redshifts here.
Each blue.is a galaxy.
And you can see this structure,
you can see the structure really cleanly,
uh,
with these void areas surrounded by walls.
And then when the walls
run into each other,
they're particularly
dance clumps of galaxies.
So that's the current structure of the
universe that we want our simulation to
end up looking like.
Yes.
Oh,
because,
uh,
after around here,
they stop being complete.
They just don't see all the galaxies
cause they're faint ones that they can't
measure.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
beyond about here,
they're just not measuring all
the galaxies that are there.
Okay.
Uh,
so now let me show you a simulation.
Let's see.
Come on.
Here we go.
All right,
I'll come back and I'll tell you what
you're looking at it in just a second.
But here is the evolution of the
universe as done by computer.
Um,
all right,
so now let me look what,
where are we starting from?
The red shift is up here.
Uh,
and so we're going to go from a red shift
of about 30 when the universe was 30
times smaller than it is
to a redshift of zero,
which is today.
And we're going to look at this box.
This is a little trunk of the universe.
Each one of these dots is
supposed to be a galaxy.
Now at a redshift of 30,
they're not galaxies yet.
They're just over densities of gas.
Uh,
now two things are going to happen
since a red shift of 30 by now.
One is that the box is going
to get 30 times bigger.
The whole universe is going to expand.
Uh,
and that is included in the simulation.
But we're not going to include it when
we make the movie because it makes it
hard to see what's going on.
And so if you remember
the coordinate system,
uh,
the way it works is there's the
scale factor times xyz position.
We're taking the scale factor out.
So this box is a single
part of the universe.
It's going to expand by a factor of 30,
but you're not going to
see the expansion here.
All you're going to see is the
motion with the motion in x,
y,
and z.
Not the scale factor.
As these things move toward each other.
Now as you start out,
it looks like it's pretty
evenly distributed,
but in fact,
there are little
perturbations in the density.
And what will happen is the galaxies
will stream toward the perturbations.
In the perturbations.
We'll get,
we'll get bigger.
And the,
and uh,
keep track of red shift up here.
The rate at which the red shift changes
varies with time because what we're
actually counting here is not red shift,
but time steps and the
relationship between time and
redshift is a not obvious.
So,
uh,
let us take another look at
the growth of structure here.
See them all moving towards each other,
uh,
collecting in these filaments,
abandoning whole regions,
uh,
into void.
And then you end up,
uh,
well you end up back where you
started the way this film loop works.
But,
uh,
let me show you a different
visualization of exactly the same data.
You know,
this is all in computer.
You can do anything you want.
They make these great things where you
sort of fly through the universe while
it's evolving and stuff.
And I don't think that's amusing,
but I don't think it's very educational.
Uh,
one thing that is useful,
they took that box and they just kept
rotating it as this film Luke Bryan around
it.
That's useful because you get to see
these structures from different angles and
I think it makes it easier to visualize.
So let's try that.
See,
it's the same simulation
except the boxes rotating.
And so you'd get a better sense,
I think,
of what these structures
actually look like.
We'll do it once more.
Okay.
As they collect into these filaments
and the filaments collect together.
And so what you can do with the output
of something like this with what it is at
the very end,
whoops,
I missed try it one more time.
Let me see if I can pause
before it gets four.
Regroups.
All right,
so here's a small red shift.
When you get to this point,
you can mathematically,
there are mathematical ways of saying,
you know,
how clumpy isn't a,
how stringing isn't,
and you can compare the results
of simulations of this kind with,
uh,
with actual observations
from the red shift surveys.
And so in this particular case it worked.
Uh,
so let me go back to here.
Yes.
Oh,
it's down here.
Oops.
There we go.
There.
That's where I want to be for the moment.
Uh,
and the consequence of these kinds
of things is it turns out that most,
as I said before,
mostly what you constrain.
Uh,
and so you compare the simulations,
okay.
Uh,
to redshift surveys.
And the consequence of that is that
you constrain the amount and also to a
lesser extent,
the type,
uh,
the behavior of dark matter because
it's the matter that's pulling things
together.
And in a way you can think about
these little clumps in filament,
that's places where the universe
has already stopped and contracted.
So it had a little extra density.
So it hit the show.
It was beyond the critical density.
So that little piece of the
universe stopped and turned around,
even though the university as
a whole continues to expand.
All right,
so now
why do we have,
let's go back to the plot.
Here's one.
Uh,
and so we have the supernovae,
uh,
forcing you to be in this box here.
We have the cosmic microwave background,
forcing you to be in this box here
and now we're going to have a straight
vertical line in this plot,
uh,
because we know how much dark matter
there is from the structure simulation.
Now,
there are two possibilities.
Supposing it comes in here,
this is a good answer
because then everything is consistent.
Alternatively,
however,
it could come in here,
this would be awkward
because if it came in there,
there would be no answer that would
simultaneously satisfy all of these
constraints.
Uh,
and so then something is wrong either
with one of these determinations of the
cosmic parameters or with
the theory as a whole,
could be other observational
badness or theoretical badness.
Uh,
and remember one,
you know,
we did assume a,
in even making this plot,
you're assuming that you're dealing with,
um,
uh,
that you're dealing with a cosmological
constant as the form of the dark energy.
And as we discussed last time,
it's possible that it isn't constant,
that it's something else.
And so if you ended up with
these things didn't work,
you'd have to ask yourself,
do I have any clue how the dark energy
works in the answer would be no.
And you would kind of have to
abandon the cosmological constant.
I think that's the easiest
out if things don't work.
Uh,
because,
uh,
dark matter,
we don't know what it is,
but we do know what it does.
It exerts gravity,
pulls things together.
So no matter what the
answer to what it is,
a gravity,
it's gravity will still
be the same dark energy.
Not only do we not know what it is,
we don't really know what it does
except that at the moment it's causing a
certain amount of acceleration.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
if you were satisfied that all
the observations were right,
you might also think that your
simulations have left out.
Something important that could easily
be that you don't fully understand how
structure evolves from the,
from a to z of 3000 to now.
That's,
you know,
certainly true at some level.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so there are various ways
you could get out of it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the nice thing about it is
it's a test of cosmology
basically.
Uh,
if you have one measurement,
okay,
of two variables,
the variables being the amount of dark
energy and the amount of dark matter
that doesn't tell you that all that
does is it establishes a relationship
between the two variables.
It doesn't actually
measure either one of them.
And so you get some allowed
region like this or this,
but you don't actually make a measurement
if you have two measurements of two
variables.
Uh,
if you think of it in
a mathematical sense,
this is two equations in two unknowns.
This you can solve.
So then you measure values
for uh oh in this case,
oh,
Miguel lambda and Omega matter.
Uh,
and that's nice.
Then you can,
you know,
quote what the values are once
you've done this to however,
whatever the precision of your
measurement turns out to be.
If you have three measurements
of two variables,
that's a test of the theory
because it is not guaranteed that
you'll get a consistent result.
In general,
if you write down three lines
in a two dimensional space,
you don't pick out a single point
because they don't all cross at the same
place.
And so if they do a,
then you've got a consistent result and
then you have tested the theory because
a,
your prediction is that all these
three lines cross at the same place.
They don't have to do that.
So if you measure something
and it works out that way,
then you've tested the theory
and kind of come out on top.
So,
uh,
let me end today's class
by showing you the answer.
This is what we know about the universe.
Uh,
let's see,
what have I done with my,
Oh,
there it is.
This is the allowed region
of the Supernova and what
they've done using each of
the,
uh,
there's a sort of,
I think it's a,
uh,
a one sigma region.
So there's a two thirds chance it'll live
inside here and a well over 90% chance
that it lives inside the broader area.
So the supernovae force you to be here,
the cosmic microwave background for is
the green result and it forces you to be
here.
And then the clusters,
large scale clustering force
you to be here and they cross.
So this is the big triumph.
You've tested the j the
theory by measuring it in
three different ways for two
parameters,
namely,
uh,
the dark energy density and
the dark matter density.
Now there are a couple other
interesting things to note on this plot.
One is that in some cases the universe
expands forever and at some cases it re
collapses and we're well
into the expansion region.
There's also the question of the,
uh,
um,
of the geometry of the universe.
The more stuff there is either
dark energy or dark matter,
the more curved the university becomes.
And so you can ask yourself,
is the universe curved in such a
way that occurs back on itself?
Is it basically flat giving you Euclidean
geometry or does it curve backwards
and extend infinitely?
And that these three situations here,
if the sum is equal to one,
then the universe is flat and Euclidean.
Uh,
and so that separates these two.
Now it says,
somebody pointed out a few classes ago,
if you have too much dark energy,
then you never cross zero and you never
have a big bag because the acceleration
has been so great that you must've
started out coming down and been bent up
toward where we are now.
That's this region up here.
No big bag.
Uh,
and so we're well away from that as well.
and so this basically sums up what we
currently know about the expansion of the
universe.
That we have a constraint going this way,
a constraint going this way,
a constraint going this way.
And you can see why I say that in,
in a kind of philosophical sense.
All three of these measurements
are equally important,
uh,
because it's the fact that you've got
three of them that allows a test of the
theory.
And we've talked a lot
about the supernovae.
You could talk just as much about the
cosmic microwave background or about large
scale clustering and the
comparison of simulations with,
with redshift surveys.
Uh,
we obviously aren't going
to have time to do it,
but this plot summarizes what
we know about the universe.
Okay.
Thanks.